thanks to brilliant for sponsoring this
video as a challenge i decided to read
the top 100 scientific papers of all
time but what does that actually mean
the top scientific papers well one
definition is looking at the citations
on those papers when scientific papers
build on work that has been done before
by other scientists which could be a
discovery or a theory or a lab technique
they will cite that work that's what
these numbers mean in papers they're
referencing a previous scientific work
that will be listed at the end of the
paper a frequent measure of the success
of a paper then is the number of
citations it receives and that's a goal
that scientists frequently shoot for
they want to write papers that will get
lots of citations so for this video i
read the top 100 most cited scientific
papers of all time by one measure that
makes them the best though it's far from
the only way of looking at it finding
those top 100 papers however was
surprisingly difficult i tried using a
python script to scrape google scholar
but that didn't work i tried using other
websites but they don't allow you to
sort by the raw number of citations so
instead for this video i used a list
compiled in 2014 by the journal nature
so the list that i'm using in this video
is a little out of date but
for reasons that will become clear i
highly doubt that this list has changed
all of that much so what's on the list
the oldest paper in the top 100 was
published in 1925 and the youngest in
2008 with the decades seeing the most
entries being the 1980s plenty of time
to accrue citations in terms of subjects
biology dominates the list 39 of all the
papers described techniques used in
biology labs and over 50 percent were
related to the study of living beings in
some way there's actually a nature
article with additional breakdown of
these statistics which i'll leave linked
below but just to add something to that
article something that surprised me
about this list was the number of single
author papers so science these days is
generally regarded as quite
collaborative and you'll very frequently
see papers written with lots of
co-authors and to give you one extreme
example the team that discovered the
higgs boson at cern published their
paper in 2012 with 2932
authors
21 of which were actually deceased it's
not that unusual to see single author
papers but i was surprised to see so
many in the top 100 list though the
frequency of those single author papers
definitely decreased as time went on
which is what i expected but regardless
of the number of authors what does it
take to get a paper into the top 100
well again this is in 2014 so the number
will be greater now in order to get a
scientific paper into the top 100 it
needs to have over 12 000 citations to
put that number in perspective the
overwhelming majority of scientific
papers ever published have received
between 0 and 9 citations if a paper
gets over a hundred citations it's
already in the top few percent of all
published papers ever so to get more
than ten thousand citations is really
extraordinary soaring above that figure
are the top six scientific papers of all
time which are all on techniques used in
biology labs
they received between fifty thousand and
three hundred thousand citations by
2014. it will be even more by now this
was a daunting start to the list seeing
as my background is in physics not
biology so i asked my friend and protein
fanboy dr alex lathbridge to give me
some reading notes on these papers and
he described them as covering the holy
trinity of bioscience research improving
our ability to research dna
rna and proteins the top paper of all
time is by laurie ettel protein
measurement with the pholine phenol
reagent this describes what's now known
as the lowry
assay now assay was a totally new word
to me when i started this project
basically it refers to a technique used
to measure the amount of or the presence
of or the activity of a thing in a
sample so the lowry assay in particular
is used to measure the amount of protein
in a sample and it uses colorimetry
which is a word that i'm probably
pronouncing wrong because it was another
new word to me in this process
basically it's a technique where you do
some stuff to a sample that causes the
sample to change color and in this
particular case the more your sample
changes color the more protein is
present this paper was at the very top
of the list because it's a technique
that scientists use
all the time chances are if you are
working in a lab and looking at proteins
you're going to use the lowry assay so
when you write up your work into a paper
you might cite lowry et al similarly the
second paper is by lim li etau
describing an improvement to a technique
called sds page that separates out
mixtures of proteins by their weights
again a technique that everyone now uses
and has to cite something the third
paper describes the bradford protein
assay a different way of measuring
protein in a sample the fourth paper is
about sanger sequencing one of the early
methods of sequencing dna so working out
the order that your g and c and t and a
bases are in a sample of dna and fun
fact fred sanger is one of only four
people to have won two nobel prizes one
for this work and one for his work on
sequencing proteins i'm going to quote
alex on the fifth paper dna is for nerds
rna is lit this paper is the first one
to describe a technique of isolating rna
which again quoting alex is the cooler
less stable sibling of dna alex also
says that he is the rna in our
friendship finally the sixth paper in
the top six describes a technique now
known as the western blot which is used
to identify a specific protein in a mix
i expected to find these bioscience
papers to be the most difficult to
understand on the list but perhaps
because the pandemic has made everyone a
bit more aware of bioscience or because
frankly they often read more like
recipes than theoretical papers i was
never too
lost by contrast
physical chemistry had 16 papers in this
list and they were
way more difficult to understand i think
partly because they were using
terminology from quantum and atomic
physics which i understand but in a
completely different way like in a
different context so i half understood
what was going on but in a way that just
kept tripping me up it was super
frustrating to read density functional
theory right
not even once okay but what else is in
the top 100 papers of all time well
what's surprising is what's not in the
top 100. chances are if you've heard of
a big scientific breakthrough it's not
on this list for example the discovery
of dna chaos theory special relativity
the schrodinger equation
none of them feature on this list that's
because this list largely describes
methods with a few very notable
exceptions as we've already seen with
the bioscience papers if a technique is
used everywhere the paper describing it
is going to get a lot of citations by
contrast big discoveries just
don't get cited as often this is the
problem with comparing the merits of
different scientific papers just based
on the number of citations they receive
for example the work of einstein has
completely revolutionized the way we
look at the universe but has received
far fewer citations than a slightly
improved method of isolating a protein
part of that is because the way science
is done has changed it's become more
formalized and bigger over the past
century but really trying to assess the
impact of
an idea of a piece of science is
inherently subjective and can't just be
boiled down to one number constructing a
list in this way
is
inherently biased all that being said
there was some really interesting stuff
in this list and i learned about some
really cool new science
some personal highlights the paper with
the best title was just
fuzzy sets this was the highest ranked
maths paper on the list and introduced
this idea of a set which is a collection
of objects where an object can be in or
out like in a normal set but also
somewhere in between which allows you to
do some interesting analysis the
shortest paper in the top 100 was by
feinberg and vogelstein and it's a
one-page addendum to another paper and
it describes a slightly improved method
of keeping track of the enzymes which
interact with dna some of the most
scientifically interesting papers to me
included saito and nay proposing a
method of constructing evolutionary
family trees based on statistical
differences between dna samples from
different species that's just so cool
weber and osborne introducing a
technique of sorting proteins based on
how they respond to an applied electric
field no vossel of it all because it's
the graphene paper this was one of the
notable exceptions to the dominance of
methods over discoveries it was a real
joy to read i never actually read the
paper before and interestingly this
paper and the paper on carbon nanotubes
were the two highest ranked entries in
the list for physics i'd hypothesize
because more papers are published in
materials science that are going to
extensively draw on graphene and
nanotubes than in other areas of physics
with the exception of crystallography
which had a ton of entries in the list
though they were basically all about
software used in crystallography and
lastly kirkpatrick etau which used a
computer algorithm to find optimal
solutions to large complex systems by
drawing an analogy to physical processes
that's interesting enough on its own but
it concludes by saying the solution is
an example of artificial intelligence
which in 1983
is kind of amazing in fact machine
learning and artificial intelligence
research are likely to be the only
possible significant disruptors to the
list since 2014 with a deluge of papers
that are being published all citing the
same statistical techniques just like we
see with lab techniques in bioscience
and interestingly this is something that
you kind of saw in the list anyway as
the further down you went and as time
went on you saw fewer and fewer
lab-based techniques and more and more
computer-based techniques or
descriptions of software though to be
honest i doubt that even the incredible
explosion of machine learning research
could rival the
frankly astonishing dominance of
bioscience in the top 100. oh and before
i draw some conclusions a couple of
bizarre inclusions in the list 61st on
the list is a paper all about
determining if a medical patient is
left-handed or right-handed
and 79th on the list is jorgensen
ettal's comparison of simple potential
functions for simulating
liquid water
this is a pretty early attempt at using
some numerical techniques to simulate
how water behaves including electronic
interactions
but i really don't understand why it's
so high up on this list can someone
explain to me in the comments why it is
i assume it's a chemistry thing
and if any one of you mentions density
functional theory i swear in this
experience i learned about some
fascinating science in topics that i
never even knew existed before obviously
not in any great detail or breadth it
was like trying to learn to play the
cello by watching yoyoma play bach for
two hours don't get me wrong amazing to
see what can be accomplished
but it didn't really help me understand
the fundamentals more than anything
it was a fascinating window into how
science is done it taught me that
biologists love assays chemists love
correlation energies and earth
scientists apparently don't like
publishing papers at all over these
papers you could see the standard form
of an academic paper coalesce as the
century went on you could see techniques
improve as later papers in the list
would cite earlier papers in the list
and science would be done in these
incremental small steps paper by paper a
phrase that you sometimes hear when
talking about science is attributed to
newton that we can only see far by
standing on the shoulders of giants
accomplishing all the wonders of modern
science by using the work of monumental
genius but this experience showed me
that science doesn't stand atop the
shoulders of giants it stands atop a
long chain of small incremental
discoveries with the real linchpins in
that chain being a handful of techniques
invented by scientists you've probably
never heard of
but used by scientists all over the
world science is to me the ultimate
human endeavor not made by giants but
made by humans and this list
is the ultimate example maybe of what
humans can do when we work
together
as i found simply reading about
interesting science isn't an effective
way to learn about it the most effective
learning is through doing to become one
of the great scientists featured in this
video it's not enough to study
you have to do this is exactly what
brilliant this video sponsor is all
about brilliant is a website and app
that improves your skills in maths
science and computer science by
introducing you to new ideas and
immediately getting you to apply them
the emphasis is very much on trying not
being correct after all if you get it
wrong what's the worst that can happen
you just improve for next time brilliant
offers interactive expertly written
courses from middle school to graduate
school level across as wide a range of
subjects as i covered in this video
everything from computational biology to
set theory and some exciting stuff even
beyond such as cryptocurrency the
brilliant app allows you to spend a
little time each day improving your
scientific thinking while the desktop
website makes for an ideal companion to
classroom learning taking the concepts
learned in school and bringing them to
gorgeous interactive life to get started
for free visit brilliant.org simon clark
or click the link in the description and
the first 200 people to do so will get
20 off brilliant annual premium
subscription for themselves or for a
student in their life thanks to
brilliant for sponsoring this video and
for being well
brilliant
thank you so much for watching the video
i really hope you enjoyed this one
because it was a really interesting
experience if a little exhausting trying
to unpick a hundred pieces of sometimes
really quite dense scientific literature
if you did enjoy the video please do
give it a like and share it with people
that you think might be interested in
watching it as well and if you'd like to
watch some more stuff like this then
what do you know i've got some other
videos on this youtube channel if you
like the look of those as well then
maybe you should subscribe that just
leads me to say thank you again for
watching and
i'll see you next time